[Music]
well it'll it'll be sunny it'll be
sticky kind of humid and hot this is
very typical for august dog days of
summer are still barking aren't they
beautiful skies this morning as that
sunrise is happening right now
temperatures have been in the low 80s
and some upper 70s but with the higher
humidity dew points are up at 60 and
humidity is up
way up this morning so it's really a
kind of a trade-off if we were had
warmer temperatures and lower humidity
feel about the same
air just feels heavier thicker when
we've the humidity is so high 79 in
boulder city we've got 80's right now in
laughlin 66 in kingman after getting
clobbered with thunderstorms in
northwest arizona yesterday 75 at indian
springs low 70s in tonopah let's talk
about the smoke that's been bothering
people since the weekend but it has
retreated as i roll the smoke forecast
you can see the concentration up around
reno is awful very unhealthy for
everyone up there in washoe county
western nevada and up in northern
california about this time last year
also that reno was having terrible
wildfire smoke problems from those
northern california wildfires lots of
heat issued heat warnings watches and
advisories
from the northeast the mid-south and the
northwest 160 million people will be
under some kind of heat alert today
tropical storm fred is out in the carib
is out in the atlantic now making its
way through the caribbean it missed
puerto rico but it will be on track to
skirt over the dominican republic headed
for cuba and eventually in line for
florida by the end of the weekend could
make landfall over parts of florida and
even the southeast u.s could even be a
minimal hurricane we're going to keep
watching fred all right those
thunderstorms yesterday flared up up
here in northern arizona but then they
started heading south with heavy rain
big outflow winds and so much lightning
they continued down into san bernardino
county caused flash flooding and
passable roads so much lightning we were
spared with thunderstorms yesterday the
mountains had big clouds we might see
some thunderstorms in the mountains
today lots of sunshine to start and then
a very slight chance for the valley with
a better chance of isolated storms in
the mountains today hot and sticky for
us 105. now tomorrow mostly sunny and
then we'll get
hotter and less humid as we get into the
weekend 108 107 next week slight chances
for storms return starting on monday